As far as going from analysis to design and
process there, here's three things that you should consider.
First off, I would suggest treating the entire system itself as an object.
And that any of the objects which you are actually going to have
in your program would be attributes of that overall system object.
Second is we just men, mentioned.
It may be the case that we're going to have to decide how to
deal with associations and invariants.
And third, as you'll see a little bit later in this lesson.
Although you're going to have in your OO design,
classes that were originally specified during your object oriented analysis,
you're also going to have some addition, additional classes.
And we want to look at what are the circumstances that would lead you to
having some additional classes.